hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast basic concepts in
transient expression using 293 and show
cells
presented by haneish you the associate
director in the Life Sciences Solutions
Group at thermo Thermo Fisher Scientific
we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
Rhodes
this event is sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific and this live broadcast is
brought to you by lab roots before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
preachin presentation window and type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the side window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem please join me in welcoming
dr. Zeile I will now turn the
presentation over to him okay hello and
thank you very much all of you who have
joined me today for my presentation on
basic concepts in transient expression
from 293 and Cho cells my my goal for
this presentation is just to give you
again sort of a little bit of a primer
some some basic ideas and and and
understanding of transient expression
systems and sort of some of the the
ideas that will really help you in terms
of thinking about how to best optimize
and get the best performance out of your
transient expression systems
so let me start off by just a really
quick introduction here you know the the
the expression the production of
recombinant proteins from a million
cells has become an increasingly
important and tool for use in life
sciences for obviously a variety of
reasons as we delve deeper into trying
to understand the structure and function
of proteins and how they they work in
our in our everyday lives as well as as
quite a lot of interest because more and
more of the drugs and the therapies that
are being developed now are based on the
use of recombinant proteins so for
example antibodies that are are targeted
to fight cancer cells or various types
of of molecules that are used to either
stimulate or block different biological
functions within our body our being
based on recombinant proteins so
expression of these proteins being able
to get a good amount of them and be able
to do research and and work with them in
the lab is a very important tool and the
classic method for being able to produce
proteins in mammalian cells has been by
the use of what we call stable
expressing cells where you transect your
gene that's expressing a protein of
interest into the cells and go through a
process to select for for that gene
stabili integrating into the cell and
then by once you have those stable cells
to expand them out to grow up as many as
you need then to produce the amount of
recombinant protein that's necessary
however that process requires a fair
amount of work and time to do and it can
take many many weeks to months in order
to create the stables obviously once you
have the stables then ideally you can be
able to produce as much protein as you
want and repeatedly over
many different expression runs okay
however over the past about fifteen
maybe twenty years or so this idea of
what I would call scaleable transient
expression has become ever-increasing an
important tool and become much more
becoming more and more sophisticated and
advanced in terms of being able to
produce recombinant proteins and a real
key idea and feature for that is that
this idea the transient expression
allows us to transfer a large number of
proteins all at once and do it very
quickly so that you can generate
proteins within a short period of time
rather than taking many many weeks to
months in order to get to obtain your
protein it literally from the time that
you have your DNA construct at hand it
can take you a week or so to generate
your protein and then a short period of
time afterwards to do the purification
to get your protein in hand so transient
expression has become a very powerful
tool for this and what I'd like to do
then in this presentation is talk about
some of those fundamental principles and
made elements of transient protein
production and here I show in the slide
what I think are really you know the key
elements in there obviously you have to
have the cells and you have a media that
grow your cultures of cells you need a
reagent there to deliver your gene
that's expressing a protein of interest
into the cells and obviously you have
the gene itself in an expression
construct so those are sort of the
fundamental elements and what I'm going
to really talk about here now there's a
lot that that can be said and probably
for a topic for a different presentation
on expression constructs and how to
optimize your gene and and that
construct to get the maximal expression
possible but I really want to talk to
you today is about the cells the media
that you grow the cells in the
transfection reagent etc because those
three elements really have to work
together in a very coordinated fashion
to get the best optimal results from you
system and so I want you to come away
from this presentation you just try to
think really about your cell culture and
what's going on in the cell culture as
you just start to manipulate these cells
in order to get them to produce the
protein that you want okay so with that
then the second part of the
introductions talk a little bit about
the cell lines that typically are being
used for transient protein expression
work HEK to 93's their human embryonic
carcinoma cells those are frankly the
the workhorse the the the main cell line
that is used for transient protein
production there's a variety of reasons
for that some of it just historical but
really it's because over time now it's
been shown that the htk 293 or 293 cells
are just a very good cell line for this
type of work they've been adapted and
many different varieties of 293 cells
have been adapted to suspension culture
which lends to the scalability that you
need in order to either transfer a small
number of small cells in a small volume
of culture or a large number in large
volumes in order to get the amount of
protein that you need there also just
are very good at express that up taking
up DNA that is transfected into them and
then expressing a good amount of protein
from those so those have really been
foreign way the the the vast majority of
the work has been done in 293 cells Acho
cells on the other hand had been of high
interest obviously just because of what
i had said at the beginning there and
that there's so much interest in
recombinant proteins because of this
idea of using them as biotherapeutics
excuse me and the and certainly foremost
biotherapeutics when it comes down to
actually producing those proteins in
order to for clinical use
in order to put them into patients many
of them are being manufactured now in
bio production settings using Chinese
hamster ovary or cho cells so and to be
able to use these cho cells as well in a
transient expression application very
early in the process to be able to
express your recombinant proteins and
cho cells can be of great value because
if you are looking at being able to
eventually manufacture diamond show
sells it would be nice to know as early
as you ten how those proteins behave how
those proteins
what type of activity they are the type
of characteristics they may have by
using the same cell line or same type of
cell cho cells if you do that and if you
do the initial work in two nine three
cells most of the time that's fine but
there aren't there can be differences in
the way the proteins are either the
conformation of the proteins are
certainly in definitely in the post
translational modification of those
proteins when they're made into nine
three cells versus chose and so that can
lead to some differences in how the
proteins react so as you're screening
through for biotherapeutics it may not
be exactly the same as a type of protein
that you'd make further wrong so those
are really far away i would say that you
know the certainly the vast majority of
the recombinant proteins being made by
transient expression area being done
either in two nine three cells or
they're ninis in a smaller percentage
and in cho however i think that over the
last a few years the the work in truss
it has been really advancing and now
more and more of it more and more
proteins are being expressed in tube in
cho because it becomes it's become more
feasible and i'll go over that a little
bit more in the next few slides so this
a slide here just shows some sort of
those Sunline trade-offs that you have
between the two nine three cells and cho
cells both of them are very good at
being adapted into suspension culture
that makes these
transient expression system is very
scalable by being able to transfer
either small or large volumes of
suspension cells the two of the really
key differences that I'm highlighting
here in red are what really are key
considerations for thinking about when
you're using 293 or when you're using
cho cells okay one is the growth rate
293 cells actually grow at a
significantly slower rate than cho cells
the typical doubling time of 293 cells
and suspension culture is around 24
hours whereas for Cho they tend to
double at around by 16 to 17 hours so
much much faster and as its played out
it's actually become evident that the
slower growth of 293 cells actually in
in this particular application for
transient work is probably a better
feature and I'll talk to you a little
bit more about why that is that slower
growing cells works better the other one
is about transfect ability and 293 cells
are highly transferable it's a very S
free fairly easy using a variety of
different types of reagents or
strategies to transfer 293 cells show
cells on the other hand typically are
more difficult or resistant to taking up
foreign DNA and so it's been I think a
lot of the the advances in the in the
last few years have really been around
this idea of how can we efficiently
transfer to 9 3 3
I'm sorry cho cells for transient
expression work and as we've been able
to either solve for that problem that's
really helped to increase the the
usability of cho cells for transient
expression and the yields that we can
get out of these transient expression
systems here I'm showing what I would
call sort of the classic sort of profile
of expression in in transient 293 versus
Cho particularly at the very top there
of showing a number of antibodies
human and rabbit antibodies and even a
by specific there and you can see that
for what I would call standard methods
that have been used for quite a few
years on 293 and show that there's
there's a substantial difference that
293 is just have have been much better
as at expressing proteins in this
transient expression application you can
see on the very top there this is a
model protein that we use quite a bit in
our work it's a very good expresser and
in again what we call our standard 293
which is represented by for example for
thermo fisher our freestyle 293 systems
that have been and available in the
market now for well over 15 years
picking at pretty good levels of maybe
up to a couple hundred milligrams per
liter and certainly it's about four-fold
lower in cho cells and that's pretty uh
it's that's not unusual to see that type
of a difference in yields now be that as
it may if you look down at the bottom of
three factor nine human growth hormone
and ebo i listed these proteins in this
particularly because even under the the
conditions were that the standard show
were that transient system for being
early user cells is not quite as
powerful and as efficient as two nine
threes for certain proteins cho cells
just have always been able to produce
more so for these three in particular
there's there's quite a few other
examples there are but that the cho
cells produce more so there's definitely
a difference for just a cell line
difference in what proteins might
express better in one cell line versus
the other but for in general over those
there's many years that the to nine
threes and chose have been used to nine
threes have typically been able to
express much much more so for us our
thermo fisher you know as we've worked
on on
an expression system certainly yield
even with to nine threes where we're
seeing where we were seeing pretty good
yields has always been a need to get to
even greater yields so over the last
about five years or so we've been
developing systems that can chant has
really helped to boost up the yields
coming from transient expression systems
and a lot of it has to do with this idea
and thinking about the cells the media
that the cells growing and the
transfection reagent that's being used
for this in order to increase yield one
of the the key strategies that has
become more and more frequently uses
this idea of going to what we would call
high density systems where you can put
many many more cells per mil of culture
into your transient expression system
and then being able to transfer at that
higher density and certainly since the
cells are really the protein factories
that are producing cells if you can have
let's say two times or three times more
cells in your culture and then are able
to efficiently transect those cells
which in and of itself is actually a key
aspect of this but assuming that you can
efficiently transfer at similar percent
transfection efficiencies those
high-density cells then you should get
be able to get more protein out of it
just because you have that many more
cells in culture now there's many sort
of considerations of aspects of it if
you have high density cultures that
means your entire media system and that
culture system has to really be able to
provide the nutrients and other key
factors to sustain the viability and
express ability of the cells even when
they're becoming much more crowded and
have many more oven in there that puts
greater demands on the culture system
itself to have these high density
cultures and similarly for the
transcription reagent it puts greater
demands on being able to transfer many
many more cells per mil of culture in
there you can imagine that if we worked
at able to increase the density of your
culture but your transfection efficiency
fell off that for example if you had
say a three-fold increase in the number
of cells but your transaction efficiency
dropped by 50% they're really not
gaining as much of the benefit of having
3 times more cells in culture as you
could if you were able to to also
increase and improve the transaction to
maintain the high efficiencies so these
three areas they are really very well
tied in together and are very important
in the Society of transient expression
work let me show you that now so for
Thermo Fisher we have developed our our
high density 293 and Cho systems they've
come out over the last few years our X
b-29 3 system our high density system
for that that we developed and came out
with about 4 actually almost 5 years ago
at this point and a high density Cho or
XP Cho system we just recently launched
in September of 2015 so a little about a
year and a half ago and here I'm just
showing you now the results that we've
taken the same proteins that I showed in
that panel a little while ago and
showing the results of how much more
expression that we can get out of these
I'll just show very quickly here you can
see now with our XP to 93 high density
system that same human IgG that's been
sort of our high-water mark and our
reference for correcting expression we
can express that on a pretty consistent
on a very consistent basis at about a
gram per liter of protein that same
protein in a high density chor XP Cho
system loops i'm never get a drawing
here on the board here we can that same
one now using the same exact constructs
that we use for our 2 9 3 systems we
when we transect that into our xB Cho we
can generate up to 3 grams of that
protein per liter so it's a huge advance
in terms of transient expression to be
able to get to these high density
systems and in coupling again a
that really helps to support the density
a transferee agent that helps to
maintain the high efficiency transaction
under those conditions you can see a
significant improvement in yields across
the word and obviously for our for that
model protein as well as for many other
proteins a significant jump in
expression so here are I'm not going to
really go through this and probably
later on this says this presentation
will be archived and you can take a look
at some of these numbers just a few
parameters about these systems and
densities at which we work at at they're
the maximum working menses etcetera
right here the main thing to point out
is that the second line here density at
transfection are xB 293 or 293 systems
we're now transfecting at about three
times more cells per mil then our
intuition original freestyle 293 system
and for xB Cho we are able to actually
transfer that at six million cells per
ml so 60 times higher a number of
proteins
let me start really getting into now the
things that I think are important to
consider and think about in terms of how
whatever system you're using whether
it's our sort of the the more standard
classic systems or these higher density
systems and whether it's from us or from
you know systems that you you have
implemented yourself from a variety of
other sources I think the the underlying
principles that we're going to talk
about to you about next are very
important so really if nothing else out
what I want you to take away from this
presentation is idea of self health and
the culture and what's really going on
there because frankly that is the key to
really getting a optimal or maximal
performance you can from whatever
transient expression system you are
using think about the cells you are
those cells to be as healthy and robust
as possible there's a variety of factors
that play a significant role in that so
most of them I or I think many of them I
point out in this slide certainly the
the particular type of cell as I
mentioned already about the the the the
the rate of growth of the cells that
needs to be taken into account the media
the formulation whether or not you have
fresh or not as fresh media in there the
age of your culture is the amount of
stress that the cells are undergoing as
they're they're being cultured and in
this sort of suspension culture system
oxygenation etc these are all key parts
of it that you should at least you know
have in your mind and think about us as
you're using these cells for transient
expression work and then this idea of a
transient culture expressing protein so
when you do do a large-scale transient
run you're transfecting a number of
cells either starting at the classic
cells which are about a million cells
per mil all the way up to now six
million cells per mil with our speed Cho
system okay now when you do the
transactions not every single cell is
going to be transfected and certainly
they don't all Express at the same level
very different from a stable expression
system there where the cells are all
integrated with the gene so you'll have
this mixed population of what I would
call productive and non-productive cells
in your culture and that's very
important to think about because there
are two different you essentially have
these these these different sort of
characteristics and populations of cells
the non-productive cells are not only
let's say not contributing to the yield
but they actually all have a active sort
of negative contribution to the culture
because typically they grow faster in
your culture and they will metabolize
the the nutrients in your media quicker
so the more non-productive non
transected cells you have in culture the
quicker the the media is exhausted the
the the shorter time that the productive
cells will have in order to express
their protein and over the next few
slides I'll just show you sort of unit a
little bit of an exaggerated form at
sort of the dynamics of what goes on in
those cultures so you start off with
Missa you can see that the picture of
you know the
or cells you have being transfected and
for most of these systems now for
example or XP 2 9 3 MX beat show we
can't achieve transfection efficiencies
of around 80 to 90 percent sometimes a
better than that but I'll say that the
survey are are are very consistent and
reasonable numbers that you should be
seeing at least in terms of transaction
efficiency so over the next few days
what's going to go on is you have these
differential growth rates between the
non transfected or non non-productive
cells into productive cells and you'll
start to see that in your cultures more
of the cells will will not be
contributing to determinant protein that
you have if you just allow them to
continue to grow at these these
differential rates so that eventually
over time what you'll see is you're
going to crowd out the product ourselves
with the non-productive cells the
nutrients are going to be exhausted and
the the overall D the expression may not
last as long as you'd like and so you
don't get as much protein out at the
very end so this sort of dynamic I've
exaggerated in these photos but it's
something definitely that you should
think about and consider whenever you're
doing a transient expression run and
when you're setting up your systems I
think how can you manage this and make
sure that your cells are doing well so
the first thing you always do when we do
that is really think about okay what are
the things that I should be monitoring
and thinking about so for us it's very
routine and really we want to be very
regimented about this we want to make
sure that we're monitoring the cells
were we're checking the growth rates -
checking the number of cells and culture
all the time to be able to really
understand what's and see what's going
on and see that in culture now I'll talk
a little bit more about we need to
maintain the cells in what I would call
early is early to mid log phase growth
that's when the cells are most
productive for protein expression and so
knowing for example at what point your
cells will reach maximal density and
start to move into static phase it's
important because then that gives you a
an idea of what the working range and
where your early-to-mid log phase both
will be for your culture then you
establish a very routine passage in
culture for us we typically do it two
times a week rather than three just
because that introduces less of that lag
phase whenever you're doing a media
exchange or actually in our case it
typically just dilution with with fresh
media so but the important thing here is
just to be very routine about doing it
on a consistent basis but monitoring
that the density of your culture is to
make sure that they're within their
early to mid block phase growth and we
also monitor the viability and the
percent viability of those cultures and
a number of passages we do and I'll talk
a little bit more about that in a second
also to avoid so clumping there's a
variety of different ways that you can
avoid so clumping sometimes it's
suggesting your agitation rate for your
cultures of the times it's making sure
that you just do some work as your path
passage in the cells to perhaps to
situate them up and down a little bit in
your pipette to try to break up any any
small clumps or sometimes it you might
if you're starting to see some
significant visible clumps if they let
the culture sit for a second let for a
little while let the clumps fall to the
bottom and then sort of terribly take
off the the cells were off the top of
your your culture a little bit of
clumping is not probably a huge concern
but certainly once you start to see a
lot of clumping typically you're gonna
have to go through these and a lot of
times for us we just just get rid of
that culture instead and have a fresh
culture started to avoid clumps okay
here I'm showing you and for monitoring
of of your cultures it's very important
that you do the the counts and
understand what the doubling time of
your cells are it should be pretty
consistent from from passage to passage
if it's not then there's something that
might need to look at and address in
your culture system how the cells are
being handled or the equipment that
you're using it cetera and here I'm just
showing them sort of typical these are
for freestyle cells in freestyle media
but the numbers are hold firmly true as
well for our high density on your
high-density XP systems 293 cells you
can see here you know for over ten
passages they calculate a doubling time
of those cells and averages out here to
be about a little bit more about twenty
five twenty six hours for doubling for
XP there are high density XP to 93
systems that drops a bit down to about
24 hours for show it's been the same
whether it's for our older freestyle or
any XP XP trio system they do they
double about every 17 hours and you can
see that they're relatively consistent
from from passage to passage now there
have been times when we've all of a
sudden notice that a culture has started
to increase in the time it takes for
that culture to double and one when we
see that happening then we start to
think that there may be something going
on in there and much of the time we'll
we'll just take those cells out of out
of our workflow and put in fresh cells
for them and in addition to this
doubling time we're monitoring as I said
the cell viability and typically most of
these most of the cultures with either 2
9 3 Acho you should be able to get at
least 95 percent viable cells
consistently all the time for our XP
systems even for a freestyle typically
we're seeing that more in like the 97 98
percent viable cells and for us that so
it's good to see that and that is
consistent if you get these two
parameters and you're seeing that very
consistently the the doubling times the
viability of the cells then like who's
that you
going to get much more consistent
results in terms of trance the protein
yield from them from one time to another
okay here I'm showing America spend any
time on this but again you can come back
to this one this presentation is
archived to take a look at this for
anybody who doesn't already have or know
this this is the formula in order to
calculate the growth rate of your cells
and so this is what we use in order to
to determine those okay so now by being
able to to maintain a very consistent
steady culture of the cells having the
consistency in that that doubling time
and the viability cetera it's very
important another aspect I talked about
is about the age of your cultures here
we did an experiment this is with our
free stop show system a number of years
ago what we did here we took them a free
stop show and thawed them out at
different various times so by the time
we did this particular study there are
our oldest cultures had been thought out
about 12 weeks previous so those are the
bars in blue and our newest cultures
have been just thought out two weeks
prior to this so that's not a bars in
black and you can see what happens this
is post transaction the expression of
IgG
and and five at one five and six days
post transfection the yield of that
eyeyou-- that we got from that transient
expression run and you can see that for
the older cultures though one certainly
at 12 weeks there's a there's a
substantial reduction in the amount of
protein that were able to get so
certainly over time the for a variety of
reasons the cells just lose more of
their production capabilities for that
so it's something that to monitor
typically for us we go out about two to
three months of culture of using the
same culture for our expression runs and
then by by the time they're reaching
close to that two or three months a
period of time then we'll already break
out fresh cultures and your switch over
to them to really mean
the maximal yields that we can from the
cells you could probably go out a little
bit longer with art with two nine three
cells than with Cho because of the fact
that they grow slower and so over that
period of time there's actually fewer
fewer doublings of those cells than with
Cho so that typically will allow you to
use those for a longer period of time
before you have to switch to a new
culture the other thing is as I
mentioned before about that being an
early to mid lock phase growth and not
allowing the cells to really get to a
lag phase or a static static phase where
they've grown to their maximal densities
aren't just sitting there if you do that
then it really does impact the yield
even if you then dilute the cells back
down and get them back into what I call
what we have early the bid lock face
growth for this particular experiment
what we did was we took the cells and
did passages but for the ones in the
blue line we only deleted those cells
down to about of May and each time as we
passaged and then allowed them to grow
for another three to four days and so
they were at that point have hit the
static face and then we passage them
back down and whereas the other ones we
passage down to lower densities and so
they maintained a little bit more of
their their early to mid log phase
growth and you can see the impact of
that that the cells that were we're
getting up into that that lag phase just
does not do not produce as much protein
as those that are maintained in the log
phase growth here what I'm showing here
is this is where again having high
density cultures and a media that can
really support much higher growth rates
or or or density sorry of the culture
can play a role I'm showing here X b-29
3 cells growing in X b-29 three media
compared to 293 cells grown in a variety
of other
you can see that the the the maximum
density that does tonight the X between
my three cells get to is much much
higher so that means that that are early
that mid lock face growth is in a
different working range and hopefully
the animation so yep here shows what
happens so the working range in that up
to mid lock phase you can see are shown
in those brackets here and for xB 293
that allows you to easily maintained
ourselves up to around five maybe six
million cells per mil and then passage
so typically passage down to maybe about
a 300,000 and then go up to between four
and six million cells per mil whereas
with these other our older systems and
other systems that working range is is
significantly reduced and that we can
really only grow their selves up to
maybe about two million cells per mil
and then we do the transactions at a
million cells per mil which is in the
middle of that range versus doing a
transaction at three million for our xB
293 okay in order to be a not quite
right in the correct working range for
those cultures here for our chow our xb2
system those cells now with the high
with the highly enriched media
formulation and the adaptation of those
cells to the high density cultures those
cells will grow up to over 20 million
cells per mil at maximum so that means
that the working range that early-to-mid
lockface growth is significantly
extended and we can grow those and
typically you're going to passage the
cells up better by the time they reach
about six to eight million cells per mil
and then drop them back down and
maintain that range and that allows us
then to do the transactions at higher
density here at about six million cells
per mil again leading to higher yields
protein yields that can come out of them
because of the higher density there's
actually other benefits for the media
the the long term adaptation into this
highly enriched media also makes these
cells both the x be cho and x b-29 three
cells you have provide higher personal
productivity so the picograms per cell
per day for us these cells in this
enriched media under these conditions to
is higher than the picograms per cell
per day that that you can achieve under
with what I call standard density
systems the the protocols for being able
to use when we have this these high
density cultures then it does make it a
little bit more challenging to do the
transactions and maintain the viability
and growth of their cells or not growth
but the viability of those cells over
over over the time post transfection I'm
showing here I won't go through the
entire thing but sort of our standard
protocol for transfer and handling into
cells for our xB Cho system and the
thing to consider here is we have not
only a transaction reagent to be able to
transfer as many cells as possible for
xB Cho typically about 80 percent
transaction efficiency but then there
there's other other aspects of the
system in order to manage that the
what's going on with those cells so
typically for us now are you know the
strategy that we've started to employ is
to think about using how to basically
shift their the metabolism of those
cells because they're they're growing we
are using those expanding and cultures
so they're in sort of a growth phase we
keep them in that early to mid log phase
growth for that but then once they're
transfected ideally what we would like
to do this slow their cells down or
actually even potentially get them to
stop growing
because of the dynamics I showed you
before with the mixed population of
cells and shift them over so that
instead of spending in at their time and
in here on doubling their spending most
of their time and energy on expressing
protein so the transcription agents that
we've designed we have what we call
enhancer transfection enhancer and then
also a feed all of those things are
designed to both to maintain the health
of the cells and also to shift their
metabolism so that they're no longer
really growing very much and using most
of the energy for expressing protein
instead and we also for our Cho system
because cho cells actually do have an
ability that and there's
the temperature so by dropping a
temperature of the cells in culture as
well you can slow them down
and shift their metabolism for growth
over into expression mode so all of
those things are play a role now in in
these more advanced transient expression
systems to think of how we can take the
cell lines post transaction and move
them over into a full expression mode
rather than in growth mode another thing
to consider is and it's important is
that kinetics of being able to make your
DNA transcription complexes there now
it's really important to understand that
when you take your DNA and put it
together with any of the cationic type
reagents that are used for transecting
whether it's the the cationic lipids
that we produce or PGI or others it's
there's um typically what happens is as
you take the DNA and add it to your
chaotic reagent you former electrostatic
complex and over time that complex
actually will continue to grow in size
and so once it gets to be very large the
transfection efficiency of those
complexes goes down so timing is
important here I show you four actually
this again is our free style trisystem
but it applies to our to pretty much any
system there what happens when you allow
the complexes set for 10 20 30 or 60
minutes and over time in each each of
the particular genomic reagents that you
can use for transcription they're going
to have a slightly different temporal
pattern for this but over time you can
see that the efficiency of that complex
rate is reduced when you do this for our
our latest x bicho system with the xB
effectively in transaction agent you can
see that we actually don't want to allow
those complexes to sit for more than
five minutes together and delay in the
transfer agent before you apply them to
the cells once you go out to fifteen or
thirty minutes you'll see a super
significant decrease in their
performance when you put
come on to the cells so that's a
definitely something important to
consider no matter what type of
transfection reagent you're using in
assistant and then lastly if I really
try to bundle together some of these
concepts what you what you should be
able to see once you transferred the
cells is a is a very reproducible sort
of behavior and pattern for what's going
on with the cells and again we monitor
this by looking at the viability of
percent viability of your population as
well as the viable cell density over
time so here I'm sharing with xB 293
culture the culture kinetics post
transfection so we transferred that here
de 0 and then monitor over the next
seven days what's going on you can see
how the viability starts off very high
at well over 95% and then for the first
several days when we maintain pretty
good viability is up above 90% but then
start to drop and accelerate in
decreasing in viability so that by
typically by the time your harvest which
is somewhere between five and seven days
for most folks you'll see viability is
around 50% or actually even going a bit
lower down into 40% if you see it much
lower than that if you're harvesting it
let's say day six or so and you're
seeing below 20% viability they're not
suggesting that there was probably
something in your in your culture or the
way that the cells are being handled
that made them a little bit less robust
and typically you'll see a reduction in
yield if you if you see that so knowing
this viability and viable cell density
curve for your particular expression
system under your standard conditions in
your incubator is very important because
that really helps to give you a gauge
and monitor what's going on
here you can see for viable cell density
for xB 293 they start off at around the
3 million cells per mil at transcription
then they will expand for the 4 for the
first several days till they get to
somewhere between let's say six and
eight million cells per mil so they slow
down and certainly if it were a non
transcriptase cells they get to that
that density much much quicker but they
do slow down but they will continue to
grow and end
sort of peak and then started to sort of
decrease again as the viability
continues to drop so these are very very
common what I would call prototypic
viability and viable cell density
profiles and curves for at xB 293 system
and four and two nine three systems in
general although the densities you know
that it would be different ranges of
densities than just even depending on
the particular system so these are
things that you want to monitor if you
see that they're there they're following
what I would call the prototypic pattern
and they're either not growing too high
in density or they're not dropping in
viability too rapidly then probably your
your cultures are going well and you're
getting maximal performance out of your
cells and you can see this that you it
should be you can monitor these and it
should be very scalable here I'm showing
at the top there xB 293 and at the
bottom freestyle 293 the red curves are
being our wave runs being done at around
8 liters of culture and the blue curves
are small shaker flasks I think in this
particular case about 40 mils of culture
in there and the viability viable cell
density should look very similar no
matter what scale you're at so this is a
important concept for scale scalability
of your systems that as you scale you're
probably going to need to adjust some of
the parameters either the agitation rate
etc and as if and by monitoring these
things that will give you a guide to how
you need to sort of adjust those culture
conditions in order to basically try to
replicate the same viability of viable
cell density curves you can do that then
typically your volumetric yield in other
words they're the milligrams of protein
per liter of culture should remain
fairly consistent across different
culture volumes that you're using here
I'm showing the connects for xB Cho
which are significantly different from
293 cells for variety reasons for cho
cells they and probably also because of
the the it's more
recent system that we've developed we've
been able to apply a little bit more
advanced techniques in terms of our
culture conditions or the media the feed
that we add to themselves we can
maintain viability with ourselves much
longer so you can see on the left hand
side the viable cell density and the
viability curves I'll start with the
viability curve on the bottom left there
start at again well you know in the high
90s two weeks now we can maintain the
viability of those cells at over eighty
percent okay and part of that is because
we really have been able to figure out
methods because of the transferring
agent the enhancer the feed and also
potentially you know depending on which
protocol you use the drop in temperature
we can maintain the the viability of the
viable cell density and shift those
cells from growth rate over to basically
being in static so you know that upper
left you can see that the cell started
about six million cells per mil they'll
grow up to potentially around ten maybe
a bit more than ten million cells per
mil and they basically no longer owe any
more beyond maybe the first couple of
days and they'll just maintain a fairly
consistent cell density and high
viability and that allows these cells
then to just continue to pump out
protein over a substantial portion of
time and this is what makes for the high
yields that you're able to achieve now
in our XP Cho systems typically what
we've seen for in various scenarios
where people where somebody may not be
getting quite as good yield is we'll see
basically that as you get out into the
later phases that the viability as
substantially dropped so that's the the
curve on the right hand side compared to
the graph on the left hand side if you
see that where they job sub
substantially before below eighty
percent that's suggesting that probably
again it's just a cultural condition so
whether it's RPMs or rock or speed
an angle or whatever is required to
agitate your cultures there may be
either too much agitation going on
creating too much stress for the cells
so that they drop in viability or
potentially also maybe not enough
agitation to get enough aeration into
those cultures so it's you know it's by
taking a look at these things seeing
that then you can start to make you know
assessments of what you need to do to
optimize your culture conditions in
order to get the maximal yields these
are essentially very important and and
and really the emphasis today is
monitoring your cultures understanding
what the dynamics of the that population
is looking like over time to be able to
achieve the highest level results so
that really is is you know the key
takeaway I hope that you get from this
presentation so just as a summary 293
cells show cells are really the most
common cells used for transient
expression the growth characteristics of
293 cells and show cells are very
different so you have to take that into
consideration about the difference in
growth rates and also the the idea that
for example 293 cells we would consider
them a bit more of a system where the
cells will will actually are pretty
robust in this continuing to grow and
then will sort of hit a maximum density
and start to die off so it's it's
continuing changing over time whereas
for true cells you're you you can you we
have systems that are able to allow the
choice else to really shift in their
metabolism so that they go from a growth
phase really into more of a just a
maintain the same density and mate but
maintain high viable
over time to be able to produce more
protein or a substantial portion of time
there over the last several years
because of the introduction for example
of the xB Cho system really now the the
I guess that which cell line produces
more protein has really changed right
now for us at least we see and not only
internally but with many of the users of
xB Cho outside of ourselves we're seeing
probably on average about a two-fold
increase in yield on xB Cho compared to
the best 293 systems that are available
out there the culture conditions which
hopefully have spent enough time on our
key critical parameters for what you're
doing so really being able to monitor
your growth your the viability also
really understanding and monitoring your
seed cultures and making sure that
they're being very consistent in how
they grow and how their passage in
lumpkin and checking on a number of
passes is very important for this for
transfection the transfection
technologies whether it's ours or others
typically are pretty robust the main
things is are paying close attention to
the timing of that transfection complex
formation and not allowing those to go
to incubate for too long before you
added their cells in culture otherwise
you can get some decreases in the
transaction efficiency so with that I am
pretty much done with my presentation
for today and thank you very much for
your time today and listening to this
and I'm happy to we've actually got the
plenty of time although I don't
obviously don't need to take it off to
take any questions that you might have
and if not here then you can certainly
send in questions later on and we can
answer them offline as well so with that
then I'm Kristin I think I'll turn it
back over to you thank you so much dr.
Chow for that informative information we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you
would like to ask please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button will answer as many of the
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is what
is the difference between X 8 to 9 3
cells and regular HEC to 9 3 cells
Kristin Hawks for that question
Oh Thank You Kristen for that question
yeah so x PQ 9 3 cells and are
essentially what I'd still call
wild-type Hector 2 9 3 cells the really
the only didn't do anything in terms of
engineering of the so what we really
basically did with them is we took our
freestyle p9 3 F cells and we did long
term adaptation into this highly
enriched media that we developed the the
X b-29 three media and it basically was
more of just an observation phenomenon
that we observed with those as we packed
and we continued to passage the 293
cells in the xB 293 media they started
to change
somewhat in their characteristics they
started to grow a little bit faster as I
showed you in one of the slides as well
as they started to produce more protein
so the peak of ours per cell per day for
those actually ended up
increasing by about 30 to 40 percent
compared to the the the is the early
adaptation of those cells into the XP
media and then after that it's sort of
stabilizing and leveled out so then we
banked them at that point so there are
really no differences genetically
between the XP to 93 and that's what I
call standard heck 293 cells there
probably are differences from a point of
view of really what gene transcripts
we've done some work to know that you
know some of the genes have increased
and other genes have dropped in terms of
their expression levels but in terms of
the genotype it's the same okay next
question
thank you doctor to pay for our next
question we have apart from using low
passage cells maintaining a high cell
viability splitting the cells according
to the expected cell density ranges
maintaining appropriate shaking
conditions or 125 to 130 rpm and
avoiding temperature shifts if you have
any advice in order to avoid xvii chose
cell clumping don't have can you hear me
okay sorry I probably might have started
before so in terms of clumping you know
the nice thing is that we've actually
found that with the XP media's and that
long term adaptation of their cells they
don't tend to clump as much but I can
certainly imagine that in some instances
you know you can get good clumping so
again it's um it's it's really a measure
of making sure that your agitation rates
are in the right range there's always a
little bit of a balance because without
enough agitation you can get more clumps
and certainly the cells may not be as as
well suspended in
culture but with too much then you're
creating too much stress on those cells
so finding that that that sort of that
ideal range depending on your particular
shaker or whatever other type of culture
of us are you using it you can vary from
one one person to the other depending on
their equipment now the other thing that
actually will have an impact on clumping
which we don't talk about as much as
temperature and when your if
particularly for example here shake
flasks that are sitting on a shaker that
shaker does give off some heat and
depending on you know how old or new
that shaker is and various models you
may have more or less heat exchange
going on there so we always actually
when we install a shaker in there we'll
put in a flask with some liquid water or
whatever and a thermometer really just
to check what the temperature is right
at the surface of the shaker and to show
cells in particular although I think 293
s can suffer from this to a certain
extent as a temperature goes up they
tend they can clump more so for cho
cells we actually like to you know 37
degrees right there at that oak in the
liquid right sitting on the shaker
platform is the maximum we want to go to
in fact a little bit below 37 is
probably fine for the Cho's they they
can withstand up to 93 s probably or
have a little bit more flexibility but
you really don't want to go much of
above 37 degrees for those and and that
that can cause some clumping
okay thank you
our next question we have what is the
effect of antibiotic or anti-fungal
agents on protein expression okay so
typically you know for these cells we we
try to understand and monitor all the
different stresses that are be impacting
those cells in the culture so we have
done some tests particularly antibiotics
I don't think we've really tested
antifungals too much you know for us
normally we avoid using them at all in
typically you know we're able to
maintain our aseptic conditions so that
we don't have to use them now it is
possible we've we have tested and we
didn't know that we can use a bit of
antibiotics in these cultures and
normally they're they're fine you have
to consider all the different stresses
that are going on and particularly xbo
cells are more stress sensitive so if
you know if you've got the right rpms
agitation rate and other things your
passages them well the cells are very
robust then taking a little bit of
stress from antibiotics or potentially
antifungal agent probably okay but if
those cells are either having either
either too much agitation or maybe too
little
oxygenation there are already under some
stress then adding that additional
stress may have an impact so so part of
it is making sure that your your culture
conditions really are just you know as
optimal as you can and then if you do
that then adding the antibiotics etc
shouldn't be too much of a problem
okay we're almost out of time now shoo
shoo this will have to be our last
on-air question
what a temperature shift be effective
for hexie 93 and increasing protein xaxb
alright thank you thank you for that
question and actually that that's a good
question to start end with it with
little time because it's actually a
pretty quick quick answer we've tested
that we've had a number of other groups
try to use that as well
and for you know basically everybody has
to come to the same conclusion that at
this point two nine three cells just
don't seem to react the same and a
temperature shift doesn't really do much
it doesn't really help them they just
chug along at the lower temperature just
the same as at the high temperature and
you probably just it either has no
impact or actually it can just decrease
the performance of the system alright
thank you very much again thank you
everyone thank you so much I would like
to once again thank dr. Shu for his
presentation and I would also like to
thank lab roads and thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible additional
questions will be answered and published
on Thermo Fisher Scientific sweb site
you will receive an email notification
when answers are available before we go
I want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April of 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye